[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the alleged boulder store shooter
ordered to be held in jail without bail
as a family of 10 victims remembered
their loved ones while ricky was living
her dream
the sister-in-law of one of the
so-called doomsday cult suspects
speaking out
why tammy dabel's sister says she was
shocked when she learned chad dabo
remarried to lori vallo
just weeks after tammy's death we break
down all the key players in the derrick
shoven trial
everything you need to know about the
death of george floyd plus
an exclusive preview of our interview
with the head of the minnesota police
and police officers association
here from the organization funding
showbiz defense this is such a
very important case and the world is
watching law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
there are nearly as many lawyers as
jurors in the trial of derrick chauvin
set to start next week angenette levy is
here with a breakdown of who's who
in the courtroom brian there are 11
lawyers
on the prosecution team the defense has
one lawyer in the courtroom and over the
next month
a very long list of witnesses will
testify in the trial of derrick shovin
my name is keith ellison minnesota
attorney general keith ellison was in
the courtroom for much of jury selection
he's minnesota's top cop and before that
served in congress and the state
legislature
he spent years prior to that working as
a civil rights attorney
let's look at exactly what this is being
offered to prove assistant attorney
general matthew frank leads the trial
team
and heads the trial division at the ag's
office
he's flanked by a rotating cast of 10
lawyers
that's what we're asking for at this
point neil catial has
appeared via zoom during the obama
administration katyal served as an
acting solicitor general
steve slicher is on loan from his law
firm he worked as a federal prosecutor
for 13 years
having an expert who can explain
medically what they are
is helpful to the jury another special
prosecutor jerry blackwell
is known for winning a posthumous pardon
for a man wrongfully convicted of rape
in connection with the duluth lynchings
of 1920.
the defense filed a single highly
unusual
expert report sunday by year clerked for
justice's suitor and breyer
at the u.s supreme court and for brett
kavanaugh when he was a federal judge
also on the team lola velasquez aguila
nathaniel zielinski
victoria joseph harrison kilgore and
danielle desalnier's stumple
he's not responsive right now bro and
there will be a long line of witnesses
including
donald williams he was there the day
george floyd died
he's expected to be a key prosecution
witness he saw part of what happened
and also has a mixed martial arts
background
hennepin county medical examiner andrew
baker will likely face a grilling from
the defense
after he was quoted by county officials
as saying absent other factors
he would have classified floyd's death a
drug overdose
and the teenage girl who filmed the
bystander video of george floyd's arrest
darnell frazier
will testify for the state
an off-duty firefighter will also
testify about what she saw when floyd
was in custody
your honor i think the court hits the
nail kind of square on the head and last
but not least
eric nelson represents derek chauvin
he's a managing partner in minnesota's
largest criminal defense firm
he's described by a friend as cool under
pressure prepared and an avid baseball
fan
he's represented clients in other
high-profile murder cases
and we really haven't heard from the
defense team in this case
they've been very quiet attorney general
keith ellison held a press conference
when announcing the charges but other
than that we haven't heard much from him
either
now one person we are hearing from
exclusively
is the executive director of the
minneapolis police
and peace officers association that is
an organization
that has members who are 911 dispatchers
police officers things like that
and they lobby the legislature for
pro-law enforcement legislation that
organization
also has a legal defense fund and it's
covering the
legal fees for the four officers charged
in this case
brian peters told me that he actually
believes that all of the officers have a
pretty good defense
i can't say too much about specifics
about the case but you will see
what training officers were given at the
minneapolis police department
you'll see quite a bit of evidence
regarding
the medical examiner's report
and you know those are important
aspects of the case that really haven't
been discussed
thoroughly and i think the public will
be able to see a lot more of those facts
and make a determination
on their own
we'll have much more of that exclusive
interview on the next edition of law and
crime daily
brian thanks angenet joining us today is
civil rights attorney dewitt lacey
and terry austin do it in a trial optics
is everything
so is this the a.g throwing the book at
chauvin
or is it david versus goliath
uh in some regards i think it's a little
bit of both now i mean yeah
optics are everything and it can
um be uh perceived by the folks on the
jury and at least the viewers of the
trial that
the prosecution is coming down really
heavy on uh mr chauvin
and you know that could make it very
tough
to uh go hard against him or uh you know
uh be a very direct in
their conviction but you know we'll have
to see just how the evidence shakes out
now terry 11v1 sounds like an extreme
soccer game
uh what are your theories on why there's
so many prosecutors here
to prosecute chovin for the murder of
george floyd
you know look i know that if you have
too many cooks in the kitchen
you could really spoil you know the
dinner basically but i think if you make
sure that everyone has a role it should
not be a problem
and what i would do if i were the
prosecution with all of these people
available
have one person focus on the opening and
the closing
have someone else focus on appealable
grounds have someone who can
do the motions i mean there are so many
things that you could just
sparse out here to make sure that the
case is tried and this is a high profile
case
i think that you need to make sure that
everyone
is on the top of their game i'd even
have someone who is focusing on
the jury charges so so i think there's
enough work to go around
exactly did brian peters say whether
chauvin's lawyer is working with the
other lawyers
for the three other officers yeah from
our conversation it sounds like they are
all working together kind of exchanging
information you have to remember that at
the very beginning of this case
all four officers were set to be tried
together
and then chauvin's case was severed from
the case
involving the other three officers so he
was going to be tried by himself so
they are all being kind of paid by the
same organization the mppoa
and they are exchanging information yeah
it makes sense it does
take a lot more than just one defense
attorney to kind of hold the weight of
an entire trial
with this magnitude and be sure to tune
in to the law and crime network for
capital gamble coverage
of the derrick chauvin murder trial in
the death of george floyd
still ahead of law and crime daily the
sister of chad day bell's ex-wife tammy
debell
speaks out about chad marrying lori
right after her sister's death
but first the nurse sentenced to three
years in jail after admitting to
cleaning up after a murder
sees her jail time cut in half
[Music]
welcome back legal avenues appear to hit
a dead end for actor johnny depp
for one of his cases in british court
depp has lost his last ditch appeal in a
libel case against a uk tabloid
depp was suing the sun for an article
calling him quote a wife beater for
domestic violence allegations against
his ex-wife
actor amber hurd a three-week trial last
year ended with the judge dismissing
depp's claim
saying the headline was substantially
true heard testified she was in fear for
her life
because of depth abuse depp appealed
maintaining that it was him who was the
victim
the judge rejected his arguments lawyers
for the son hailed the ruling
as a victory for the freedom of the
press and for victims of domestic
violence
everywhere an idaho woman who admitted
to helping her boyfriend dispose of his
fiance's body has been re-sentenced
flight instructor kelsey barath went
missing on thanksgiving day
in 2018. her fiance patrick frazee was
found guilty of first-degree murder
based on large part of the testimony of
his girlfriend crystal kenny kenny said
she got rid of barrett's cell phone
after frazee beat her to death with a
baseball bat kenny was sentenced to
three years
she appealed on the grounds that her
sentence was unconstitutional
saying she was not advised of her
blakely rights defendant was charged
with a class six felony
so in colorado the presumptive sentence
is up to 18 months but what the judge
did
was the judge found aggravating
circumstances
and increased that sentence up to three
years
well there's this supreme court case
called blakely and essentially what it
says
is that if a defendant is going to
receive a sentence that is
above the presumptive range
then based on certain facts then a jury
must find those facts beyond a
reasonable doubt it's not something the
judge can just
you know eyeball and say oh this case is
particularly egregious
kenny was re-sentenced to 18 months in
prison the judge said in court that he
believed the punishment was too short
for kenny's cold
calculated and cruel actions with credit
for time served
kenny will get out in four months
back with us at civil rights attorney
dewitt lacey and terry austin
terry looks like the judge was bound by
law to give the max of 18 months
but what do you make of his remarks
afterwards
you know what brian i totally agree with
judge cells i think the punishment was
too short
there's no question that she was cold
and calculated she really could have and
the judge said this
she could have stopped this crime
because she knew it was going to happen
because her boyfriend was asking her
repeatedly to help him
kill you know his ex-fiance so i
definitely think that
she should have gotten as much as she
possibly could have
and that you know what is occurring is
this 18-month sentence is really going
to be
applied and she's already going to have
time served she's only going to serve
about four more months so
you know i think she got off very
lightly for a very serious heinous crime
i i totally get that do it but on the
flip side
she testified helping to get a murder
conviction without the promise of a deal
and got the maximum penalty for the
charge she was charged with it's not
like she got something lower
could the issue probably be that she's
getting out too soon well that's
certainly what the court seemed to think
the court believed that she was getting
off too leniently
uh and he wanted to make sure that the
message was sent
loud and clear that anybody who engages
in this type of behavior and especially
miss kinney
was going to be subjected to some pretty
uh i guess
harsh uh punishments uh but
she the law only allows her to get to 18
months the court
just doesn't have the right then to uh
as was said in in the preview
to eyeball it and add on some
enhancements just because uh he felt so
passionate about it
yeah often times when you see things
like this like we're in the past
we've looked at jennifer doulos's case
with jennifer's law maybe we'll see a
lot
coming out of this case where there'll
be greater punishments
for things like this because i think we
can all agree i don't know driving and
going down to this distance and
participating in the cleanup this way is
definitely something that maybe should
have more than 18 months in jail but
we'll keep eyes on that
coming up on law and crime daily accuse
a boulder store shooter's
first court appearance the charges
prosecutors could be adding to the case
plus the doomsday couple back in the
news the family members speaking out for
the first time
in an interview you don't want to miss
[Music]
next
the sister-in-law of the so-called
doomsday cult suspect
is speaking out terry austin has been
closely following the saga and explains
why this new interview
is so shocking brian so many people have
been affected by this
case including tammy dabell's only
sister
samantha lori valo and her husband chad
debell are facing charges
for an alleged plot to conceal and
destroy evidence while valo's children
were reported missing authorities
discovered the bodies of jj
and tyler ryan buried in shallow graves
on daebel's property
before lori chad was married to tammy
davell for 29 years
tammy died in october 2019 at the
time chad said she died in her sleep but
law enforcement now
say her death is suspicious and have
exhumed her body for an autopsy
tammy's sister says she was shocked when
she found out
chad had married lori just weeks after
tammy passed away
she told nbc's dateline that chad did
appear emotional after tammy's death
i got a phone call from chad telling me
that she had passed away in her sleep
how do you process something like that
um you don't
i mean like there's just so many
thoughts running through your head
and a lot of it was like no that that
didn't happen
what did chad say happened that she'd
been sick and had a
coughing fate and passed away
how did he sound on the phone he sounded
upset and devastated i mean i was crying
and he was crying and
yeah it was a really hard moment
back with us as civil rights attorney
dewitt lacey terry
there's so much smoke in this case
it's surprising there's not an amazon
for size
fire how does this interview affect the
big picture
for valo and daebel look i think the big
picture
is six people around lori and chad have
died
under suspicious circumstances in just
two year period here
and you know we have of course we have
jj and tyler we have
charles laurie's ex-husband we have
tammy
chad's previous wife we have alex lori's
brother
and don't forget we have joseph ryan who
was ty lee's father so
it's unclear how many of these deaths
will get into the current case here
in fact you know it might be more
prejudicial than probative
and we don't even have the murder
charges yet but i do
think that these deaths are suspicious
and that at some point
it's going to come back to haunt chad
and lori and if they can tie it to this
cult belief
and all of these other deaths who knows
maybe it will get into the case
that's kind of my question i know about
these facts you know about these facts
our viewers know about these but will
these get into
a potential trial for either chad
daybell or lori valo dabo
uh um i don't think so uh because the
trial right now is about the deaths of
the children
uh and the death of uh you know chad's
former wife
uh is not really gonna be relevant
although
uh it is going to be very high profile i
can't really think of a circumstance in
which
it would be relevant to the death of the
children joshua
and ty lee but i would imagine
the prosecution is going to do
everything they can to imply
uh something about these other deaths
and and i agree
you know from first blush the very first
time i heard about this case
none of it's passed a smell test for me
yeah i
i can't think of a way this comes in i
agree with you but i bet you the
prosecution is thinking of a way that
this comes in
i will make sure to keep an eye on that
case when we come back
the first look at the boulder store
shooting suspect after the deadly
rampage that left 10 people dead
when when to expect more charges next
welcome back the accused boulder store
shooter appeared in court for the first
time
as prosecutors announced their plan to
file more charges
ahmad al-isa wheeled into a colorado
courtroom thursday morning
the suspect going before a judge on 10
counts of first-degree murder
and one count of attempted first-degree
murder any statement that you do make
canada may be used against you boulder
police say alelisa
went on a deadly shooting rampage inside
a king super grocery store on monday
afternoon
right now you're being held without bail
ten people were killed in the shooting
including 25 year old ricky olds ricky's
uncle
describing her as the light of their
family ricky was pursuing her dream of
being a store manager at king supers
ricky's co-worker and friend says
ricky's nickname was wendy for her long
braids
ricky at work she would dance to the
music
we called it her gorilla dance she would
fill her arms
anything to make you smile to make you
laugh if
you were having that bad day ricky was
there to make it better
also killed was boulder police officer
and father of seven
eric talley the boulder police chief
becoming emotional while talking about
tally
saying the shooting is personal i just
had that officer's
whole family in my office two weeks ago
to give him an award
law enforcement honoring tally with a
police escort on wednesday as his body
was taken to a funeral home
his cruiser now a memorial outside the
police station
the flowers align the fence outside the
grocery store as a community awaits
justice
the people have filed a complaint and
information
charging 11 counts al-alisa's public
defender told the judge
her client suffers from an unspecified
mental illness and asked to postpone his
next court date
our position is that we cannot do
anything until we are able to
fully assess mr alisa's mental illness
alelisa's defense
said they cannot assess him until they
receive discovery prosecutors say the
investigation
is still ongoing i will say the crime
scene has not yet been
completed in terms of processing we will
be filing additional charges in the next
couple weeks
you've discussed this with your client
he understands that he'll continue to be
held without bond
uh during that interceding three months
or so yes your honor
david alisa's defense attorney is
already talking about competency
trying to get him assessed in a case
like this should we be expecting to see
a potential insanity defense
absolutely absolutely that's exactly
what they're going to go for as a matter
of fact i don't see that there's any
other
way that they can have some type of
uh legitimate defense uh come time of
trial
insanity is is what they're going to go
to it seems to be what they're already
positioning for
and i think you can expect that coming
now terry
more charges to come i would think
they'd be stacking them on top of each
other because there's no death penalty
in colorado
but what charges do you expect to be
filed and would or
should there be plea negotiations in a
case like this
well i don't think there should be any
plea negotiations but i do hope
they stack up the charges here in
addition to the 10 counts of murder in
the one attempted murder count
they could charge him with the resisting
arrest they could
possibly charge him if it turns out
there were any drugs that he had in his
system
and we know that he purchased this gun
that they could investigate to determine
whether or not it was legally purchased
and you know we also know brian that the
fbi
has him on a list because he was
previously known
to be linked with another individual so
there could be some charges
after the fact here if we turn out that
there's some
information there for the fbi coming up
with this uh
additional link to this additional
person absolutely and like i said like
we've said before
march 23rd of 2020 the death penalty in
colorado
was abolish making the 22nd state in the
country to do so
so expect to see multiple charges and
also the word
consec as the prosecutor tries to
consect those charges
on top of each other dewitt terry thank
you for joining us and thank you for
joining us here long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
welcome to prime crime tonight another
day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the long crime network is everywhere and
we invite
you inside the jury box this is lawn
[Music]
crime
[Music]
you